[Music]
in flat earth news
oh I believe it does a pancake with
butter on top do you I love flat
earthers submitted by everyone at JK has
inspired me to rule the world nobody
could be better you're not gonna do that
that's my [ __ ]
give up your dreams right now [ __ ] not
my friend
I really meant to do this just kidding
kidding you could rule the world in your
own space
just kidding look look magic a man
brought a bubble level on a plane to a
bubble level on a plane to prove the
earth is flat this is not true this is
very true you gotta be [ __ ] kidding
me
so he said I can't like looking at
everybody else like they're dumb you
think this yeah so flat earthers think
that we are the idiots that just
believes this huge conspiracy that the
world is brown well I got a question for
the flat earthers what benefit guess do
spiracle thieriot theorists get yeah
like what what I don't understand how
it's trying to find that - yeah I could
I was googling it I'm like wow what wool
are they pulling over our eyes exactly
what though like it doesn't make any
like eye the people who believe in
Illuminati the diabolic viola for
[ __ ] crazy ass group that controls
everything there's a purpose bankers
controlling everything there's a it
makes sense the conspiracy makes sense
9/11 being fake even that one you know
the conspiracy whatever but like the
flat earthers like saying that the
spherical world is just oh you're
[ __ ] lying to us this whole
that's kind of like it's really funny
reading like what benefit do people get
from lying about it that's the thing
that they can't answer and also to buy
government for our flat earthers how
come they all look stupid as [ __ ]
Buffy get out I mean like I want to see
like one flat earther that looks at the
credible [ __ ] human being you know
and then maybe I'm like this person
probably has something to say you know
like let's say if it was some sort of
scientist doesn't believe in traditional
science right he goes that's actually
wrong and let me explain to you why you
know and then we can go through half
this whole conversation but every time I
read of are not reading I'm sorry watch
a flat earth video
it's nonsense there's no backing behind
it so I can't figure it out I just
imagine this full on the plane waiting
for the lights to try not to fall asleep
yeah it's [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] stupid is
you can go over the South Pole so if the
[ __ ] earth was flat like that if you
go if you go toward the South Pole right
what ends up happening is that you go
past into space yeah so if you but you
know you go to the [ __ ] South Pole
you come back around like that so this
is what flat earthers believe is the
world that we live in that's awesome I
think it's a dick and that we're living
under this dome yeah but if you [ __ ]
go from Australia right or what is that
what is this right I think it is
Australia and if you go this way and you
go toward the South Pole then where the
[ __ ] does the plane go does it go back
up here and it go back out oh yeah
explain it's [ __ ] stupid because you
could do it you can go past the South
Pole this is their explanation has took
like why the Sun moves in different ways
[ __ ] I could make diagrams all
day [ __ ] [ __ ] some stuff so flat
earthers believed that the Sun orbits
the earth in this direction and that the
int that the centre of the earth is
where the North Pole is and that's why
it's really cold there because it's the
furthest point of the Sun but if the
[ __ ] Sun is on top of the North Pole
wouldn't it melt no cuz it's a good sign
up its saying that oh it's a like an
orbit so the Sun goes
every 24 hours and the edge of the thing
yeah that's what they believe
so I'm going to show you how they
explain that it's winter in Australia
this summer over here but this is why in
the northern hemisphere we get longer
warmer days in the summer a shorter
cooler days in the way that doesn't
explain anything I know but that's
that's what they're saying that it
orbits this way I could look like an
infinity circle yeah oh I could look at
telescope footage right now and it shows
me the earth but you know what it's
probably a conspiracy because everyone's
gonna spend all this [ __ ] money to
not to lie to us correct me if I'm wrong
I might be wrong I'm not sure about this
but art bridges like long bridges like
when architects like built them across
like they're it's like based on the
curvature of the earth isn't it I think
so I think I read that when I was
looking into the whole flatter thing I
think cuz that's that's what that [ __ ]
is yeah yeah this is like a [ __ ]
sucker Boosh it's man yeah so I'm gonna
show you guys this video that kind of
went viral right now it was flat
earthers and those are something he's
calling it the spirit level so that
bubble level doubler wait he filmed the
bubble level or a spirit level yeah I
guess that's another name for it a
spirit level so wait wait wait he just
got something and called it like he gave
it a cosmic magical name no no this is
the [ __ ] spirit I can't sing scotch
tape exactly okay huh it's always like
things an actual table just an actual
term for this level level spirit leveler
also it's not like some [ __ ] flat
earther tool no okay because I was
getting it like these are these are soul
catchers yeah that's what it was renamed
to a bubble level okay because that's
what we know it anyway so this is his
video trimmed down it's a lot longer
than this obviously let's see this [ __ ]
here we go tell believe that [ __ ]
bought a plane ticket to prove his [ __ ]
no he thought oh and one thing that
anybody can do this is a simple
experiment that anybody can conduct to
determine definitely that earth is flat
you know to grab ten dollars go down to
your local hardware store pick up one of
these spirit lockers
have to be this brand I'm not getting
paid by Swanson to promote we not have a
spirit level and take it on the plane
with you now I say take it on the plane
because if we're living on a spinning
ball or a globe that's 25,000 miles in
circumference around the equator pouring
the curvature math then the plane should
be constantly dipping its nose forward
in order to compensate for the curvature
curvature matter yup I wonder what the
guy next time was thinking he's like a
flat earther
dude they throw all these [ __ ]
numbers around like what I can't you
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you know how the plane compensates
right it stays level and it just goes
down or up so instead of going like a
plane like the plane is not a [ __ ]
basketball it flies up like this and
then it comes down like this oh my god
wow that's kind of like okay so if this
was the plane right you see the water
stays pretty much leveled because the
plane doesn't do this and the plane
doesn't it's not going like this it
doesn't go like this it's like it's yeah
you're not like this the whole time like
the number one thing that flat earthers
say is that we're we're living on a flat
earth because you can't see the curve of
the earth like I see it all the [ __ ]
time if I look out into the horizon if I
go on to a [ __ ] plane especially a
plane ride and I look outside the window
well the whole plane thing is that
they're saying that they made that the
windows they made the windows I feel
like people are just hardcore trolling
though I don't know if this is real he
looked like you did you see this ending
the right in your face people on his
comments like well haven't you thought
about this well how did you do for a
living
I don't know I got a no because from
that t-shirt he looks like he's poor
that t-shirt look like he used to be red
and now is the Sunkist orange be washed
away too many times like if he told me I
was an astrophysicist from MIT cool this
is something you've been studying you've
been thinking about for a long time as a
new theory of yours this one looks like
he works at Best Buy or some [ __ ]
nothing wrong with Best Buy
I don't think he's a troll I think
people there's a handful of people troll
in and dumb people like this are
catching on to that [ __ ] and becoming
believers I feel like that's happening
oh man I gotta start our cold tequila
Shack
Kyrie Irving VOB and Shaq believes in it
too
Shaq you are such a [ __ ] loser dude
anything that Tila Tequila endorses I go
that's [ __ ] so she was abducted by
aliens alright so think about that [ __ ]
Shaq bellezza actually let me take check
back because I can't find that yeah I
don't think it's Shaq cuz if there was
check I've never watched anything he
does yeah let me thank sex unless he
said like I stopped the world flat I
believe it because he's like for Kyrie
Irving was one of them for sure
why is even a thing yeah so they're
saying that Google searches for the term
Flat Earth have gone up 800 percent
since 2014 why can't people just believe
in aliens like normal [ __ ] yeah
what's wrong with aliens yo yeah I just
stick to the normal [ __ ] alien JFK
conspiracy murder [ __ ] like Illuminati
just stick to that [ __ ] man this flatter
[ __ ] is like way way stupid so then what
is their argument from having the earth
to be a sphere what do you mean like
like what makes them believe that it's
completely flat like other than like
where the Sun is positioned how its
rotates like mainly the the fact that
you can't see the curb like on a plane
or no matter how high you are you can
see it just from Griffith Park you see
from everywhere you can see that the
earth is going like this everywhere so
that has been proven false because it's
always just the Contacts and glasses yes
right all right did I see all search
really put a curve thing in there so it
makes it everything well so that theory
has been proven false because it's all
due to perspective so because of the
fact that we are so small relative to
the size of the massive earth we can't
see the full size of the planet nor its
curvature no matter where we are because
we're so tiny compared to the entire
earth that's what Thursday no no so
that's that's the the that's proving the
flat earthers
wrong so then they're saying like a test
that you can do is when you see a boat
sailing away into the water you're like
you're gonna see the bottom of the boat
dip under the horizon line first because
of the curvature of the earth like if
the earth was really flat no matter
where we are on earth we would see Mount
Everest or like that's right from a
distance yeah buildings like there's no
way we're on a flat earth so question
what would they say to like the earth
photos that astronauts took from it's
part of all the community because you
have to think about it like this - right
if in fact that is [ __ ] true that the
earth is absolutely flat we could have a
high-powered telescope right from here
if we can see through the sky them is
weakest see straight all the way
thousands of thousands of miles out so
if we had a telescope and we shot here
we should be able to see like China for
me oh yeah because um thank you for my
flat earthers perspective this is all of
our telescopes yeah all the telescope's
are manufactured by the government
around our thirst yes you need to invent
your own telescope that's right I got to
do that I don't even know why we have to
even talk about this and convince dumb
[ __ ] like what oh [ __ ] that stupid [ __ ]
like stupid as [ __ ] that we have to even
entertain these [ __ ] and anybody even
listens to them and in smart people are
actually trying to convince these people
what's real like fog dude if you're that
smart
let the dumbass be a [ __ ] dumbass
that's always say that's true you listen
to crackheads yelling and talking to
themselves
no then let the [ __ ] people believe
in a flat earth all this ride home if
they take over and now there's like more
flat earther than there are smart people
oh yeah well I get mad at a dog licking
its [ __ ] - Donna looking at [ __ ]
exactly
you know I let my dogs I say hey stop it
really I let them look it but you know
what this is entertaining though yeah
reading this I was entertained because
I'm like another thing it's like well
when you see an eclipse on the moon you
see it around our shadow is round like
how cool yeah you see the Earth's shadow
on it when it's [ __ ] curved like that
you don't believe so they believe the
Sun is round and the moon is round but
not us nurse - I know that's a good
question
I'm telling you that the [ __ ]
telescope thing is just that's all you
need like just I'm tired think of the
simplest solution to prove them wrong as
they get a high-powered telescope
[ __ ] look at it this way and if you
don't see [ __ ] Mount Everest or you
don't see [ __ ] China shut the [ __ ] up
true but you know like people like this
nothing can convince them otherwise once
they believe because they're born dumb
yeah they're [ __ ] stupid I got to get
these people and use a pyramid scheme on
this game flat earther and then that's
it you guys anybody that believes in
Flat Earth things they're probably gonna
believe your [ __ ] - so you could
find and cuz I'm pretty sure if I
started a pyramid scheme and they found
out that the people that I skied we're
flattered Thursday be okay with it
whoa JK news fans I hope you guys liked
that video once again remember if you
want to be involved just submit some
articles in while suck your dick now but
seriously though there's more videos up
there
[Music]